There are
newly revealed
text messages
that show how some of the biggest names
at Fox News actually felt about the bogus
election fraud claims
that they were pushing
at the same time on Fox's air.
So these messages were revealed
as in court filings.
This is part of a Dominion's
billion dollar lawsuit against the right
wing media channel,
CNN senior media reporter Oliver Darcy.
Joining us with more.
So these documents,
perhaps in some ways
with their revealing, is not surprising
to folks who work in the media.
Maybe people in Washington
but maybe revealing
for a lot of dedicated viewers.
Yeah, I think this
this court filing,
the messages contained in it
really expose Fox News
as frankly a propaganda machine
in search of profit.
You see that
the top executives,
people like Rupert Murdoch
as well as the top hosts, people
like Tucker Carlson,
Sean Hannity, Laura Ingraham,
they knew, they privately knew
and acknowledged behind the scenes
that the election
fraud claims
being pushed by President
Donald Trump's campaign were bogus.
They were not true.
And yet the network allowed
these claims
to make its way onto their air
and they were shy about fact-checking.
In fact, in one case,
one of the Fox News correspondents,
Jacqui Heinrich,
the White House correspondent,
Fact-Checked, a tweet from Trump
pushing election denialism.
And behind the scenes,
Tucker Carlson
and Sean
Hannity talked about
how they could get her fired
simply for four fact
checking for
doing her job as a reporter
when you're supposed to report the truth
and put only the facts out there.
That's precisely right.
And she she wasn't fired.
She's still at the network.
But that tweet that she did post
Fact-Checking,
the president did eventually come down.
I think this shows
how void of any journalistic ethics
the people at the top of Fox News were.
They were not caring about
what the right thing to do as a reporter,
as they were caring about
not alienating their audience.
They were afraid of the audience
and afraid of Donald Trump.
And these messages,
they're really quite damning
and they reveal it.
Oliver, as these messages were revealed
has Fox News been covering
those revelations in the last 24 hours?
Fox News is surprisingly not covering
the revelations,
exposing their own network.
And I would also note that the
The Wall Street Journal,
which is owned by Rupert
Murdoch, has also not covered this
as well.
Fox News, I should say, is accusing
this of dominion of cherry picking quotes
in this court filing.
But I went through it.
I mean, it's
hundreds of pages
and they
they lay out a mountain of evidence
that is
it's really an indictment of the network.
So in part of that, too,
we've been pointing out
in some of this,
Tucker Carlson pointing out
Sidney Powell is lying, by the way.
I caught her. It's insane.
Laura Ingraham
says Sydney is a complete nut.
No one will work with her.
Ditto with Rudy.
Carlson actually says it's
unbelievably offensive to me.
Our viewers are good people
and they believe it.
That one really sticks with me.
Our viewers are good people
and they believe it.
And we're going to keep spoon feeding
what we know are lies to them.
It's so I mean, Tucker Carlson,
despite saying these things went on air
last night
after this court filing had come out.
He went on air last night and cast doubt
on the 20, 20 election
at the top of his program.
This is what these people do.
They don't care about the facts.
They know behind the scenes
that the election was not rigged,
that it was not stolen.
And yet
in search of profits, in search of power,
they go on air
and feed the audience this nonsense.
And they know it's nonsense
and they still do it.
And I don't know what there is
to say about it,
but it does expose this network
as not interested in the facts,
not interested in the truth,
but interested in telling the audience
what they want to hear
so they don't
and above all else,
holding onto that audience. Right.
They don't want to lose those numbers.
They don't want lose the eyeballs,
the advertising revenue, the numbers.
Oliver, appreciate it. Thank you.
Thank you.